[Musique]
les époques
angers quand d'aventuré zapper
encore un bon j'avais dit que j'avais
démissionné
la production m'a convaincu de rester
nos héros viennent de découvrir que le
méchant qui veut modifier le temps n'est
autre qu'une deuxième iris et le docteur
simon était au courant et il va tout
nous expliquer à j'ai hâte d'écouter
pour info la production l'a doublé mon
salaire bah allez papa du monde réel
explique pourquoi il y a deux versions
mois deux versions de moi tu veux dire
très bien du surf en jeu je vais tout
vous raconter au fond je n'ai jamais
vraiment été un très bon père ça on le
sait déjà
racontez nous pourquoi mon double veut
détruire on voit le peu après qu'on
évacue hitler dans une faille
spatio-temporelle j'ai commencé à
ressentir un sentiment étrange
c'était le regret j'ai regretté de
mettre si mal occupé de toi iris hors du
coup j'ai décidé de vous excuser auprès
de votre feed et de repartir sur des
bases plus saines loi mais non pas du
tout bon vous savez la simulation auto
provient l'autre top je vous ai menti à
propos de cette simulation
ce n'était pas une simple expérience qui
a buggé non face à mes regrets d'avoir
est un mauvais père et bien créer un
monde parfait avec une nouvelle iris un
monde virtuel où j'étais un père présent
et affectueux
hammond simple et heureux ou iris avec
une vie des halles puis gelé extraites
de ce monde virtuel
je les imprimés pour qu'elle devienne ma
fille et i7 viry ce qui nous menace
actuelle marois est clairement le pire
plan que j'ai entendu de ma vie c'est
pourquoi tu es méchante iris en mousse
watts méchante
vous plaisantez j'ai vécu toute ma vie
dans un monde parfait et sodas je suis
projeté dans ce que vous appelez la
réalité un monde qui pue où les gens se
tuent où il ya du sexe où tout est très
attendu où y'a pas de cette assimilation
pas que je vais pas trop vite ma fille
se fasse bois terre mais c'est pour ça
qu'on a détruit le kama sutra pas être
coincé dans ce que vous appelez la
réalité j'essaie de la reprogrammer pour
qu'elle ne devienne plus supportable tu
voulais supprimer le sexe c'est pour ça
que tu voulais détruire internet
oui pour supprimer la pornographie et
aussi les commentaires négatifs
j'aime pas ça je suis susceptible je
déteste twitter très bas ma pauvre ton
plan n'a aucun sens vous dit quand je
veux utiliser match
d'accord il pourquoi le titanic parce
que c'est le premier film que cette
illusion de père m'a montré quand je
suis arrivé ici j'ai découvert la
tristesse à cause de ce film ah bon
qu'elles sont timorés but marqué moi je
croyais que c'était un film cool non bon
je me suis toujours endormie avant la
fin et les machines de guerre et la
puissance américaine et les esclaves
vous m'avez empêché d'améliorer votre
monde donc je vais faire
modifications que j'aurais dû faire
depuis le début je vais vous éliminez
avec mon désintégrateur proton et
ensuite je prenne enfin re définir le
monde attend maintenant pour la s'écoute
ils sont mus ya quelque chose que tu as
mal compris sur notre réalité tu vas y
aura toujours un humain pour créer une
arme pour inventer le porno il y aura
toujours un humain pour tuer un autre
humain tu vois tu essayes de changer
l'histoire mais ça changera jamais
l'humanité
tu peux faire autant de modifications
que tu veux faut que tu comprennes
qu'ici on est tous comme ça fait que de
la merde alors pour cette arme je crois
qu'il a raison d'être gaulliste est vrai
trois mois tu ne peux pas changer
l'humanité
c'est vrai mais oui je ne vais pas vous
tuer tu m'a ouvert les yeux
je sais ce que je dois faire car des
29es l'hyatt en retour ni va mettre un
mot que dieu vous autres pourquoi un
dieu à abraham au parti on a loupé
l'occasion et ouvrir le crâne n'a pas
tué clairement le pire perds tu mets
tout le temps ton intelligence
scientifique au service de ta bêtise
émotionnel mais on n'a pas de temps et
tu vas commencer par te rattraper tout
de suite est-ce que tu arrives à
détecter leurs traces temporelle a tenté
un sens oui choix c'est cordonnerie ça
fait loin s'en faut les suivre
j'ai l'impression que ça va mal finir
papa toi tu bouges pas et tu fais rien
d'accord tu arrives à vous je vous
préviens il ya une majoration d'environ
2,5
vous voilà arrivé à destination il y à
66 millions d'années on n'oublie pas mes
cinq étoiles chaudes par ici ça je tu il
fait bon mais ya une petite brise c'est
comme ça de vous dire oui dit ouvrez
l'oeil et trouvez moi cette [ __ ] de
fausses mois avant qu'elle fasse
n'importe quoi ces dinosaures c'est
encore moi qui suis maître où ils ont
pas du tout la tête qu'on imaginait moi
je me pose le cernil 2 or on n'a pas le
temps de discuter zoologie thomas les
dinosaures ont toujours été comme ça
plutôt grand balèze avec de belles
plumes aux couleurs chatoyantes cherche
plutôt la fois ces listes parce que je
me suis permis de checker vous n'avez
pas encore pris le temps de mettre mes
cinq étoiles une seule fois et justement
c'est d'être plus nous qui le conduisent
à des grosses boules de neige aucun sens
d'un point de vue scientifique
c'est vous qui avez décidé qu'il n'y ait
pas de plancher sur le pod kb vote 9
je savais pas que le robot pouvait voler
vous avez vraiment des options de plus
en plus folle d'embauché la cup
c'est vrai il ya des la torre la plus de
100 options supplémentaires mais non je
suis sûr qu'il y en a au moins 72 pas
très utile dit qu'un sale traître ou les
amis de faire c'est fou les traîtres la
mauvaise foi agit comme un humain bravo
mon pote
alors comment ça se passe à liberté pour
l'instant ça consiste beaucoup à obéir à
une autre et ris donc ça change pas
grand chose d'eux c'est normal que le
soleil s'approche
ce n'est pas le soleil c'est une
météorite c'est quoi une mutuelle
oui
et encore mieux vous serez aux premières
loges pour voir la destruction de sacs
médian étant les dinosaures qu'on
pouvoir tranquillement
jamais le jour remplacer thomas pour cet
hiver
pour rappel pour moi
en train d'annuler l'espèce humaine
alors coup trop loin mon match
keystone un maire doté cloués au sol
c'est pas comme si on avait un robot
capable de voler nous regardent et là
j'ai vraiment un bon cru du
vous voulez un dernier café en attendant
c'est pas le moment un allongé site avec
tous eu comme tuner câble et 25
la météorite est suffisamment proche
d'être là accroche-toi
glass works en raison de la fonte oui
elle fait des cafés frappés avec et ça
marche très bien pour détourner les
météorites aussi des 10
ton café moi j'aime pas le café glacé
c'est encore une option débile
merci
en plus de mes théorise très bientôt
plus dieu ma caméra tu as posé au sol
atterrissage
a perdu alors les perdants ça fait quoi
de se faire annuler comme une bête
simulation c'est fini china's cadets à
place du lay chan c'est mon défi j'ai eu
une dernière chose à faire dans le futur
sinon elle a gagné
l'humanité va disparaître les dinosaures
sont pas moins la bonne nouvelle c'est
que vous n'allez pas être coincé ici
longtemps vu que je dois tout
la bonne nouvelle c'est que je vais
utiliser ma jeunesse birnbaum branche
charbon
il ya tout protège moi j'ai une question
d'abord pourquoi et risque de nous a
abandonnés peu importe
pourquoi tu poses toujours autant de
questions d'un bug aide mois plus tôt à
tuer tes anciens maîtres du chip haute
et que je ne suis pas d'accord quoi
monsieur le robot soit disant humain va
me faire croire qu'il a du libre arbitre
elliott c'est moi qui fais ok il voilà
qui avait porté vélo tu vois tu ne fait
qu'obéir stupide machine à temps c'est
pas du café c'est des jeux thomas tu
vois je fais ce que je veux je suis
libre contrairement à toi qui ne fait
qu'obéir j'ai trahi mes amis et
maintenant je ne les abandonnerai plus
facile d'abord jeu mot tout détruit dans
ta face de ça laisse la paix autour des
fictions dont les abris
ainsi s'achève la vie de nos héros
corrigez vos livres d'histoire
les derniers humains sont morts il ya 66
millions d'années dans une explosion de
machines à café les dinosaures vont
rester sur terre très et continuer
d'évoluer et croyez-moi re voir un
dinosaure et qu'un petit chapeau dans sa
voiture électrique aller à son boulot de
community manager a pas c'est rigolo un
atout des wheat les laisse mourir
doucement même temps vous avez dit gelés
pendant à peu près cinq ans oui j'ai
fait un feu quand les robots ont fait
boum il ya dû voir qu'est sorti du
méchant repos et ça vous à transformer
en glaçon moi j'étais de l'autre côté il
ya du feu qu'est sorti d'elliot ce qui
explique cette brune et c'est quoi cette
armure ultra bada
je me suis construit cette armure à
partir des restes des robots elle fait
du café d'ailleurs donné raison au fait
vous ça fait du bien
mais la buse comment tu as fait après
l'explosion j'ai ramassé des bouts de
métal dans l'un d'eux y avait un papier
c'était un message et une notice génie
trois ans à construire l'armure tout en
me nourrissant denis 2 or et de fruits
fermentés tendre et miath est détruit
c'est voir ce papier
enfin nous a déjà fait le coup une fois
diversement se re télécharger dans une
autre machine et en soutenant ce marc
désolé on dirait un vrai adieu mes amis
j'espère que vous pourrez lire ce
message je me sacrifie malheureusement
je n'ai plus de sauvegarde car il n'y a
plus de futur je crois que j'ai compris
ce qui différencie l'humain du robot
c'est la mort
en disparaissant je veux mourir comme un
homme comme un ami qui veut vous
protéger si quelqu'un trouve ce papier
j'ai mille notice pour construire une
armure avec mes composants il n'y a pas
besoin de savoir lire
ce sont des dessins si vous connaissez
ikea vous devriez vous en sortir mais
subtil pourquoi ces sacrifices des toits
qu'il n'est pas mort enfin cet art
vraiment aidé à tuer tous les nino's or
quoi inventer une gelée vous avais dit
qu'il fallait tuer tous les nids 2 or
c'est ce que j'ai fait sur la terre
entière
ouais c'est pas grandi dans l'armure m'a
aidé à me déplacer vite rien tué
il ne reste plus que ses deux petits ni
deux heures dans une cage à garçon et
une fille je suis dit que ça vous ferait
plaisir d'en tuer on s'en fait nous
remercient n'abusant plus pour vous du
1er ri blessé sur mais bon c'est la
seule façon de sauver l'humanité
maintenant le deuxième temps la buse
syrien n'a plus qu'un il pourra pas se
reproduire
donc on n'a pas besoin de l'éliminer là
bas ça veut dire que ça a marché
l'humanité je veux à tout prix se
recrutent il y deux autres millions
alors si c'est le dernier dinosaure je
vais l'appeler date
bien vu de quoi aller c'est vrai tu
connais pas le dessin animé le quoi en
tout cas c'est mon ami et bien plus
encore même si la mère terrorisée non ça
doit être lié au fait que tu aies
exterminer sur une espèce bon allez en
route petit lapin ok mais vous savez
j'ai un prénom et sur l'application
pourquoi pas étendre en mai nous thomas
la buse en août
non les familles laissez moi j'ai trouvé
ma place au calme avec denver
je me suis construit ma petite vie ici
et j'ai vu des gros insecte qu'on l'ait
retrait un petit ça auront tu es sûr bon
bah merci pour tous la buse
tu peux te fier à sauver le monde n'a
pas le temps pour me mettre 5 étoiles
mais pour faire ses adieux tout mon
temps pour voir l'ami je suis sûr qu'on
va se croiser avec la nouvelle
cicatrices ton armée en mécanique est
ton ami dinosaures est un tout nouveau
style
si des gens voulaient de dessiner il
serait de quoi s'amuser en route vers le
laboratoire
ça me fait vraiment bizarre elliott est
parti pour de bon mais c'est quoi ça
épisode 10
on a enfin donné le scénario du prochain
épisode
vous savez quoi je ne vais pas le lire
et découvrir la fin de la saison comme
à la semaine prochaine
merci d'avoir écouté et à la semaine
prochaine pour le dernier épisode de
l'épopée temporel